it's been about five years since you
made your
big screen debut and yoga hosers your
dad was also in that with you do you
guys ever
see yourself acting again together you
know i think uh i think
uh we won't ever see the planet i want
to be honest with them
about everything i loved this movie it
was literally lord of the flies
in space two of my favorite things
um did you guys read lord of the flies
for this what kind of training
or prep went into it into being in in
the space of it all
i did not read lord of flies in
preparation for
this this film but obviously awareness
the classic story you know
um about you know struggle for control
and
in power and i think in this film it's
very it's very unique and nuanced you
know because
of the backdrop it's set against you
know and and
the midst of space on this you know a
very long voyage to a far distant planet
and uh you know mainly focused on these
these 30 people on board this shoot
all 18 19 years old you know coming of
age they're coming
coming to groups with their uh with
desires that they're feeling for the
first time
and a certain feeling
i'm scared there's nothing to be scared
of
lily rose what about for you yeah i
heard the costumes were very hot and
sweaty
i mean we were we were shooting like in
the kind of peak of
summer in in romania so it was
definitely like really
really warm and yeah there was a lot of
uh a lot of uh sweat
for sure we definitely got our uh you
know our steps in our miles and for that
thing
um but yeah i mean i think you know the
prep for this one was really interesting
because you know there's
usually you have kind of like the
characters uh you know
what you imagine to be their backstory
like you know to kind of nourish the
character and
and how they may be when you meet them
in the movie but obviously
there kind of isn't that opportunity for
these these kids because they've been
you know literally created for this
mission and have known
nothing outside of that world and so i
think it was uh
it was an interesting challenge like
working with that but i think uh the
most important for me was really
connecting to the
very human uh emotions that my character
is having and all these kind of like
very
normal questions that she's asking
herself i think it's normal to kind of
sit with these questions of like
who do i want to be and what do i want
my life to mean and all of these things
and
uh and so yeah i think just connecting
to those feelings was was key for me and
uh connecting to her i'm not drinking it
what does it feel like to feel something
how was it to play
the villain it's great i mean it's great
fun to play the to play the bad guys
you get so much you've got so much
freedom to make
big decisions that you might not if you
were playing a slightly
softer character colin farrell is also
in this
how was it to work with him uh it was
amazing
i mean i only had a couple of scenes
with him but he's
it was just great to be around him and
sort of learn from him on set
he's just yeah his reputation proceeds
and he's an incredible actor
um and a very genuine uh lovely guy
there she talks into the water
he's coming from us we're eating
something toxic
we do see in this movie that the the
young men and women
don't like that their blue drink is
being tampered with
and as a result they start rebelling
which is also just part of i think being
young
and part of venturing into adulthood
did you ever go through a rebellious
phase or what is the secret to keeping
the good head
on your shoulders i think everybody
probably goes through a bit of a
rebellious phase and
i mean i think you you're gonna stand
for what you believe in you know and if
it's
in your reason makes sense to you i
think you know i'm that
i can be stubborn in that way i'll also
be rational about things
yeah reasonable but um but yeah i mean i
think that that's
you know i of course whenever when
someone's being rebellious i think that
they
they believe that they actually you know
are making the right decision i've just
had
you know good good role models in my
life you know who
who i trust and love and look up to and
learn from
oh what about you really i mean i i
think that for me
it's you know i think those rebellious
phases are
are uh inevitable and just like part of
growing up you know you can't be like
perfect
all the time i mean nobody's perfect you
know period i think that's uh
that's just like the fact of of life but
i think that you know
uh a big part of like keeping a good
head on your shoulders is uh
just having a lot of like self-awareness
and and never feeling like
you take yourself too seriously i think
it's always good to uh
you know have a good self-reflection
about the things that you've done and
and always thinking about how you could
be better because like i said you know
none of us are perfect i would never
think it uh beneficial to arrive at a
place where you're just like i'm good
i've made my bad choices and my good
choices and now i'm good you know i
think that life is just like a
always a uh you know a search for just
like you know a quest for
goodness and how can i be better and be
better for myself and for the people in
my life and uh
yeah i love that space yeah i think i
think that everyone goes through a
rebellious phase when they're
like a teenager um
i yeah i think i think that's just sort
of part of growing up
is that you push the boundaries and you
see what happens um i'm very lucky that
i'm
i've got an incredible family and
wonderful
friends around me that keep me very
grounded as you guys
have navigated hollywood what have you
learned about
the fame part of it all that it's like a
silly side effect of uh what we both
really love doing you know like i i
think i can speak for both of us when i
say that like we just
really really love our jobs and we're
both really passionate about it and and
feel really
grateful and and privileged that we're
able to wake up and do things that we
love to do
and uh and you know there's there are
other things that
come along with that that i can't say
i'm very uh interested in what's
interesting to me is uh
you know beautiful storytelling and
complex characters and and things like
that and so that's really
that's the only uh interesting part of
it for me i mean
i i don't i wouldn't consider myself a
famous person you know i walk down the
street and no one bothers me
but i do you know i do see a lot of
people around me you know that
that are you know have the same you know
do the same profession as i do and
and uh you know maybe they you know they
they um
they deal with it a bit more it's
amazing that the people
watch your work and are moved by it and
can tell by it and
you know welcome it into their lives and
share it with their friends and family
or whoever
and uh so when you look at it in that
sense you know
the impact that it makes on people i
think that that is
the most special part about storytelling
or any art form
it's an ability to affect other people
lily rose
um it's been about five years since you
made your
big screen debut and yoga hosers which
is exciting
time just goes by so fast yeah time
flies your dad was also in that with you
do you guys ever
see yourself acting again together do
you look at projects together
you know i think i think uh never say
never you know
that's really not something that i uh
you know um
that i that i consider first and and
foremost what's interesting to me is is
my
is you know the particular character
that i may or may not be playing and
then the story that it's telling and
everything but yeah i mean i
i i love to work with with great actors
you